fueron tan sólo 40 segundos de vuelo
marciano el pequeño helicóptero engine
huir y despegó con éxito desde la
superficie del planeta rojo flotando en
el aire a unos 3 metros de altitud antes
de descender y aterrizar sobre el cráter
pero en marte una noticia que puede
recibirá con vítores desde el centro de
control en california informa que ha
realizado el giro el despegue el ascenso
el vuelo estacionario el descenso el
aterrizaje los datos del altímetro
confirman que el ingeniero ha realizado
su primer vuelo de una aeronave con
motor en otro planeta el helicóptero de
propulsión solar y tu historia al ser el
primer vuelo con motor controlado en
otro planeta pero tal hazaña no podría
haberse hecho sin su compañero en marte
el rover percibir que facilitó la
comunicación con el equipo de misión en
la tierra debido a los casi 300 millones
de kilómetros que separan ambos planetas
la nave fue diseñada para ejecutar
instrucciones de forma autónoma tenemos
tres objetivos que están en línea con
los objetivos de la agencia de la nasa
el primero es demostrar aquí en la
tierra que es posible realizar un vuelo
con motor de
en la fina atmósfera de marte y ya lo
hemos hecho el mismo ingeniería envió
una secuencia de imágenes mostrando su
propia sombra proyectada sobre la
superficie y el persé vivientes también
captó un vídeo de la proeza
el éxito de este debut podría llenar el
camino para nuevos modos de exploración
en marte y otros destinos del sistema
solar
export también abre la puerta a la
exploración humana y el helicóptero
puede entrar en zonas que el rover no
puede
hay muchas cuevas y el rover tiene que
superar muchos obstáculos en el suelo
que idealmente el helicóptero puede
sortear por eso es una gran opción poner
un vehículo aéreo en otro planeta
fuera después de un gélido vuelo el
ingenuity tendrá un día de descanso para
recargarse usando un panel solar antes
de volver a volar en los próximos días